dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir artificial
neural networks are computer programs
that try to approximate what the human
brain does to solve problems like
recognizing objects in images in this
piece of work
the authors analyze the properties of
these neural networks and try to unveil
what exactly makes them think that the
paper towel is a paper towel and
building on this knowledge try to fool
these programs let's have a look at this
example one can grab this input image
and this noise pattern and add these two
images together similarly as one would
add two numbers together the operation
yields the image you see here I think
it's fair to say that the difference is
barely perceptible for the human eye not
so much for neural networks because the
input image we started with is
classified correctly as a bus and the
image that you see on the right is
classified as an ostrich in simple terms
bus plus noise equals an ostrich these
two images look almost exactly the same
but the neural networks see them quite
differently we call these examples
adversarial examples because they are
designed to fool these image recognition
programs in machine learning research
there are common data sets to test
different classification techniques on
one of the best-known example is the M
nice handwriting data set it is
basically a bunch of images depicting
handwritten members that machine
learning algorithms have to recognize
long ago this used to be a difficult
problem but nowadays any half-decent
algorithm can guess the numbers
correctly more than 99% of the time
after learning for just a few seconds
now we'll see that these adversarial
examples are not created by chance if we
add a lot of random noise to these
images they get quite difficult to
recognize let's engage in modesty and
say that I myself as a human can
recognize approximately half of them but
only if I look closely and maybe even
squint a neural network can guess this
correctly approximately 50% of the time
as well which is a quite respectable
result therefore I think random noise is
not real
fooling the neural networks however if
you look at these adversarial examples
in the even columns you see how
carefully they are crafted as they look
very similar to the original images but
the classification accuracy of the
neural network on these examples is 0%
you heard it correctly it gets it wrong
basically all the time the take-home
message is that carefully crafted
adversarial examples can be used to fool
deep neural networks reliably you can
watch them flounder on many hilarious
examples to your enjoyment my dear sir
the Queen wears a shower cap you say I
beg your pardon if you would like to
support two minute papers we are
available on patreon and offer really
cool perks for our fellow scholars for
instance you can watch each episode
around 24 hours in advance or even
decide the topic of the next episodes
how cool is that if you're interested
just click on the box below on the
screen thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time